here's the story from the New York Post
Biden says he's seen confirmed pictures
of terrorists beheading children in
Israel President Biden said on Wednesday
that he has seen confirmed pictures of
terrorists uh beheading children in
southern Israel following initial
reports that up to 40 babies were
butchered over the weekend in homes near
the Hamas ruled Gaza Strip quote I never
really thought I would see and have
confirmed pictures of terrorists
beheading children I never thought I'd
ever anyway that's one way to end that
statement I think we actually have the
clip uh not here but uh here let's play
this one I mean I I I've been doing this
a long
time I never really thought that I would
see and have
confirmed pictures of
terrorists beheading
children I never thought I'd
ever anyway I uh but there
are countries in the region that are
trying to be of some help including Arab
Nations now still with this I'm not I I
I'm not absolutely convinced and and the
issue is one I'm not about to start
believing Joe Biden to dud dis corrupt
as they come there are special interests
that want war in the Middle East the
these people despise Donald Trump and
one of the strongest re one of the
biggest reasons is that Donald Trump was
trying to bring peace to the Middle East
Donald Trump was trying to remove you
involvement when when uh we talk about
how Russia did not invade Ukraine under
the Trump Administration they say yeah
it's because Trump was serving Vladimir
Putin I'm like yeah I mean maybe it's
because Donald Trump was like this is
none of our business we should stop
supporting these these these Terror
groups whether directly or indirectly we
should stop invading these countries for
oil and mind our own business and Russia
was like well if you're not pressing on
our borders we're not you know we've got
no reason to fight they get Trump out
they come in and it's War it's conflict
it's expansion and so this this
narrative is extremely shocking based on
the videos I've seen it's it's it's
unfortunately whether whether you want
to accept it or not it's easy to believe
they did this right that's the scary
thing well they also thought Trump was a
lunatic yeah they thought he was a loose
cannon they had no idea there was some
meeting that actually Tucker told me
this story working on this that Trump
leaned over to Vladimir Putin and said
if you invade R if you invade Ukraine
when I'm president I will nuke this
out of Moscow and Putin believed him and
nobody wanted to mess with Trump they
thought he was a total loose canon which
of course I don't think he was at all
but that I think is a good a good it was
a bad image to have it was not a bad
image to have you kind of want the rest
of the world especially your enemies to
think that about your leader for sure
yeah for sure they don't want to be able
to predict you I mean the the problem
right now is that the loss of life is
always tragic violence is obviously
detestable but Joe Biden is not a
trustworthy president and so it is hard
to believe anything that would come out
of his administration even if it is
something awful like this you don't want
to believe they would lie about being
able to confirm this on the other hand
you just can't trust them look at
everything they've lied about that's
yeah and again we mentioned horri the
New Year testimony from 1990 that got us
into the first Gulf War I don't like the
way he said the word confirmed in that
speech he said the these pictures I've
seen confirmed like it was like um he
was dropping the word like they there a
talking points make sure you say the
word confirmed when you talk about this
I said yesterday prepare for deep fake
that we're in another modern This Modern
War it's going to be technology you've
never seen before utilized and when they
tell you some something happened and
then some days later you're going to
start to see blurry images or images be
wary don't snap to emotions well there's
here's a really funny one Don Jr posted
a video it is extremely graphic it is
brutal
and it is of Israeli civilians being
killed by Hamas Community
notes were placed on it saying old video
and fake because a pro Palestinian
activist uh posted a screenshot of a CLI
a thumbnail of the video over and over
again with the date of 2016 or something
like that but it is believed now that
that was fake and the video is real and
now wired has contacted the government
and done a deeper analysis on on on I
guess the metadata and the video and
found Donald Trump Jr was correct the
video was from Israel and it appears
that activists are trying to make fake
screenshots to trick people into
thinking they're fake yo we are in a
whole new world of information Warfare
it's entirely possible that wired got
bunk information from the government to
convince us the videos are real who
knows what you but but I I will I will
defer to if you've got the Biden
Administration and Donald Trump Jr and
like everyone's kind of like yeah this
is probably
true I think you're going to have to go
with that right if if people who
absolutely despise each other are like I
you know this one this is real then yeah
if both Waring parties are agreeing on
it then well it doesn't seem farfetched
from what we know about this group of
people like nobody thinks this isn't
something they wouldn't do you know
there there are undeniable videos yeah
right so there there are videos where
it's like I don't know what this is
right it's a guy and it's like running
through a field and I'm like the video
that Don junr posted was tough it's like
people in a room being shot and I'm like
man that's brutal but then there are
videos that are very easily and
discernibly of Southern Israel at an
event where you can corroborate the
pictures of the music festival and
you're watching people be shot and it's
just like this happened like we know
these videos are real that's the easy
thing where it's like the story of of
these babies being killed beheaded you
don't need it Hamas did it and not only
that mad respect to Max Blumenthal
coming on the show and talking about
he's more Pro Palestine but he outright
said hamas's strategy is to Target as
many civilians as possible to use his
bargaining chips for against Israel they
are kidnapping I that's their tactic he
called it a target of opportunity and
I'm like make no mistake this is not in
dispute we we know what they're
doing I was thinking you know it's
horrible it is absolutely I mean it's
one of the most horrific things you do
to kill somebody and to kill a small
child is like the most horrific thing
but like what's more horrific if if
someone cuts off the head of a baby or
if someone blows up six babies with a
bomb yeah yeah Tim's right like you
don't need it they don't need this to
sell the case so the the the rational
for faking it doesn't make any much
sense right and and the other thing too
uh I think it was it was you know there
were a lot of people that were critical
of Max Blumenthal because he does have a
more prop Palestinian stance but he
knows a lot about this and he actually
pushed back on some of there there's a
conspiracy theory going around that
Israel knew this was going to happen and
a lot of people are pushing it some
prominent personalities saying that they
knew it was going to happen they let it
happen because now they can use as an
excuse to go into Gaza and do all of
this stuff and bomb them and Max was
like no way absolutely not he was he
said Israel uh uh was humiliated there
uh uh many there there's a lot of
private technology and security firms in
Israel that Pride themselves and being
the best and this is true because I've
covered this stuff going back 10 years
with occupy there are many surveillance
companies that are born out of Israel
that are like we're the best Israel
proves it this is is extremely bad for
for these for for the uh this sector the
security sector and he also wanted to
mention things I don't want to I don't
want to uh comment too much on because
I'm not the expert on it but the the
military doctrine that Israel has in in
terms of captured IDF soldiers is so
extreme he said Israel would never allow
one of their soldiers to be captured I
mean the idea that they let this happen
is just there's no way yeah and that's
he's Pro he's more Pro palestin I mean I
think I find it interesting I think the
big problem is going to be the Deluge of
information especially fighting war in
the technology age right we're going to
have videos that surface from wherever
we're already seeing that Community
notes are they're they're finding ways
to work around these potential
safeguards that we have uh the thing
that I saw a lot today was parents
warning or parents groups warning
parents to have their kids delete Tik
Tok and all their social media platforms
while this goes on because it's
permeating through all the algorithm so
you having young teenagers seeing very
violent images and of course that's
deeply serving on the other hand if
you're cutting all kinds of people off
from information not that teenagers
should see violence it starts to get
very dystopian right we don't know
what's real and we don't know who should
be seeing it we don't know where to stop
it from coming from man the community
notes thing I think was obvious it is
good that you have these Community notes
because some of these things are very
easily and provably false but I have
seen on more than one occasion people
manipulate Community notes it's it's
basically if enough people say something
is true they'll just run with it and
then you end up with Community notes
that are like unrelated to the tweets or
in this instance someone made what
appears I I guess the story would be
this guy's screenshot was fake to trick
people it's remarkable Don Jr posts a
video and then some guy posts some
screenshot of with with no website
address it's a pictures of thumbnails
with a date on it and that was enough
for people on community notes to say Don
Trump's posting fake news I mean amazing
is commun notes any better than
Wikipedia right Wikipedia can be edited
and Wikipedia self-censor so we don't
really know what information is provable
there's a reason we tell high schoolers
you can't cite Wikipedia or maybe
Community notes in your term papers uh
it's all you got to follow the sources
and the interesting thing was that the
source on this community note was some
guys's tweet and then and now people are
responding to John Jr being like wire
did a a a deep analysis on the video and
found the source and said it's real like
it was recorded here here's all the
confirmation it's crazy apparently there
are like other angles or something I
don't know well I and especially in Don
Junior's case I'm sure they want Don Jr
to look like he is promoting something
crazy because of his last name you know
it's sort of a trap from the beginning
for him yeah or but wed was forced to
defend him which which they did not like
no thank you yeah uh we were talking
about this before the show that it's
there's a lot of um people who thought
they were on the same side who are now
realizing perhaps they are not when it
comes to this issue and I think that's
going to be uh maybe a I I obviously I
don't want it to be born on you know the
backs of death and violence but on the
other hand reconciling that it's not
just the two sides and no one has any
Lane of compromise is sort of a hard
thing to put American culture through
it's just so hard to believe because
we've always known I guess like you're
talking about like BLM and antifa we've
always known that about them we've
always known that about the college left
that they were super super prop
Palestine violent
be damned but I don't think left
realized it I mean I'm maybe not the one
to ask but I think I think because I had
known people who would come out as you
know I I have Jewish friends who have
come out as Pro Palestine years and
years before and it would really shock
their community and I found that to be
interesting uh it's not something that I
would necessarily have a personal
ability to comment on but I think there
is more division than they realize
because there especially the progressive
left is used to being a unified front
all the time thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 P.M and become a member over at
timcast.net